[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le Tantra vous connaissez
avant que je vous en parle je vous
propose qu'on construise ensemble un
espace protégé juste pour vous et moi un
petit espace intime à 500 plus les
millions de personnes qui vont regarder
la vidéo
alors pour ça je vous propose de mettre
vos mains comme ça
et puis vous imaginez que vos mains sont
contre les miennes et ensemble on crée
une grande bulle alors on y va
pour que ce soit encore plus confortable
je vais enlever de cette bulle ce dont
je ne veux pas pour ce moment et puis
vous pouvez faire la même chose
alors j'enlève le trac qui est en train
de serrer mon diaphragme un peu là
j'enlève la fatigue
j'enlève l'envie de bien faire
et puis je vais appeler ce que je veux
pour ce moment
alors j'appelle
j'appelle l'ancrage
j'appelle la tranquillité
j'appelle la mémoire
j'appelle la fluidité la connexion
la conscience
le plaisir la joie
alors le Tantra qu'est-ce que c'est
le Tantra c'est un chemin spirituel
laïque non duel et qui est basé sur
l'expérience
c'est un chemin spirituel parce que ça
permet de grandir de se déployer et
aussi de se connecter à bien plus large
que nous
c'est un chemin laïque parce que bien
que les racines du Tantra se trouvent en
Inde et au Tibet dans des traditions
très anciennes ça n'est rattachée à
aucune religion
c'est un chemin non duel parce qu'en
Tantra on regarde la vie d'une façon ou
les choses ne sont pas classées en noir
ou blanc on est dans du non jugement on
cherche plutôt à regarder l'infini des
possibles
et enfin le Tantra c'est basé sur
l'expérience c'est-à-dire que c'est un
chemin qui n'est pas dogmatique il y a
pas de réponse uniforme pour tout le
monde chacun va trouver ses propres
réponses à travers sa propre expérience
alors il y a trois notions importantes
l'expérience la conscience et la
vitalité
quand je fais du Tantra je vais vivre
des expériences qui sont inhabituelles
des choses que je ne fais pas dans ma
vie courante et ces expériences vont
faire émerger mes résistances mes
blocages mais aussi mes forces tout ce
qui est fluide pour moi et je vais
prendre le temps de mettre de la
conscience sur tout ça pour sentir ce
que je vis réellement à l'intérieur de
moi
on expérimente aussi des techniques qui
permettent d'augmenter notre énergie de
vie et de la rendre disponible quand on
le souhaite
alors quand je peux allier la conscience
de ce que je vis et ma vitalité et bien
là j'ai le pouvoir extraordinaire de
pouvoir choisir ma vie je choisis ce
dont je ne veux plus je choisis ce que
je veux garder et je peux même choisir
ce que je veux acquérir
puisque le Tantra c'est une histoire
d'expérience je vais vous proposer d'en
faire une là maintenant tout de suite
alors prenez le temps de fermer les yeux
quelques instants et juste observer ce
qu'il se passe dans votre corps
est-ce que votre corps est complètement
détendu est-ce qu'il y a des petites
tensions voir des douleurs quelque part
est-ce que vous vous sentez dynamique ou
plutôt un peu lourd
que se passe-t-il dans vos pensées
que se passe-t-il dans votre respiration
on fait juste un petit état des lieux et
puis maintenant je vous invite à vous
lever
mais oui vous pouvez y aller
OK et on va se secouer tous ensemble en
mettant du son alors on y va OK
et puis on va faire ensemble trois
grandes respirations alors je vous
montre on commence par gonfler le ventre
on gonfle tout le bus jusqu'à soulever
les clavicules et à l'expiration on fait
aussi du son on fait le son de la
détente ça fait quelque chose comme ça
on y va trois fois
encore une fois c'est trop bon
je sais pas comment c'est pour vous mais
moi je sens que ça commence à faire de
l'espace ici puis il y a des petits
petits mots partout là dans mes dans mes
bras par exemple
comme je suis chanteuse de jazz pour
aller un peu plus loin je vais vous
proposer d'offrir votre vibration
qui est si personnel et si unique
en offrant votre voix à un voisin ou une
voisine
autrement dit je suis en train de vous
offrir la possibilité de chanter ici au
carré magique
alors concrètement
concrètement déjà vous le faites pas
tout de suite et c'est pas mal
concrètement ça veut dire que vous serez
par deux et qu'à tour de rôle vous allez
offrir votre voix si vous le souhaitez
donc la personne qui offrira sa voix ça
veut dire que vous ferez un son tenu en
direction de votre partenaire le temps
d'une expiration quelque chose comme ça
[Musique]
et pour les personnes qui écouteront la
proposition c'est vraiment de recevoir
ce cadeau qui va vous être fait dans
votre cœur
alors avant de le faire prenez le temps
de sentir ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
de vous quand je vous fais cette
proposition
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans votre corps
dans votre respiration
[Musique]
dans vos pensées
est-ce qu'il y a plutôt de la pétanque
ou plutôt du recul face à cette
proposition
souvenez-vous qu'il s'agit juste de
mettre de la conscience
l'important d'ailleurs ça n'est pas de
faire forcément ce que je propose
vous pouvez tout à fait adopter ou
adapté ma proposition vous pouvez
toujours faire moins je vous demande
juste de ne pas faire plus
l'important c'est de mettre de la
conscience sur ce qu'il se passe à
l'intérieur de vous et de ne pas vous
juger
parce qu'au bout du compte que vous
fassiez l'expérience telle que je la
propose ou que vous la fassiez
différemment c'est toujours une
expérience qui vous permet d'apprendre
quelque chose sur vous
donc essayez de ne pas vous juger
et si jamais malgré tout vous vous jugez
alors essayez de ne pas vous juger de
vous juger
alors si vous le souhaitez c'est le
moment de vous tourner vers quelqu'un
on dirait que c'est déjà pas si simple
OK
alors vous êtes maintenant
vous êtes maintenant en duo face à un
partenaire ou alors peut-être en solo
parce que vous avez choisi de rester en
solo ou peut-être en solo parce que
l'organisation de la salle fait que vous
n'avez pas trouvé de partenaire et tout
est bienvenu
tiens au fait
qu'est-ce qui a motivé votre décision de
vous tourner ou pas vers quelqu'un
quel a été votre moteur est-ce que c'est
la curiosité la préhension
est-ce que quand je vous dis
tournez-vous vers quelqu'un alors vous
le faites de façon un peu automatique
est-ce que quand je vous dis me
tournez-vous vers quelqu'un alors
justement vous ne le faites pas de façon
un peu systématique
ou peut-être que vous êtes fatigué et
puis que vous vous êtes dit ça va être
trop dur pour moi peut-être que vous
êtes fatigué que vous a dit ah chouette
ça va me réveiller
et si vous êtes en solo et que vous ne
l'avez pas souhaité qu'est-ce que vous
vivez la frustration du soulagement de
la curiosité
toutes ces raisons tout ça c'est bien
venu
tout ça peut exister
alors maintenant vous allez prendre le
temps de sentir de quelle façon vous
souhaitez offrir votre vibration
est-ce que vous souhaitez offrir votre
voix à votre partenaire ou à l'univers
si vous êtes en solo et peut-être vous
avez envie d'offrir votre silence
tout ça est possible tout ça est
bienvenu tout est juste
pour les solos vous allez pouvoir à la
fois offrir votre énergie à l'univers et
l'accueillir dans votre cœur
dans les duos
hey dans les duos c'est la personne qui
a les cheveux les plus courts qui
commencera à offrir son énergie alors
vérifiez bien
et l'idée
l'idée quand j'offre mon énergie et ma
vibration que ce soit sonore ou
SILENCIEUX l'idée c'est vraiment je
t'offre quelque chose de moi
et pour vous qui recevrez ce cadeau
laissez-vous sentir que ce cadeau quel
qu'il soit il est précieux il est unique
il est intime alors honolère honorez-le
en le recevant dans votre cœur
alors c'est maintenant et vous pouvez y
aller donc soit solo soit les personnes
qui ont les cheveux les plus courts
je t'offre quelque chose de moi en
faisant peut-être un son
[Musique]
OK
prenez le temps de sentir ce qu'il se
passe à l'intérieur
est-ce que est-ce que ça a été qu'est-ce
qui a été facile qu'est-ce qui a été
plus compliqué
est-ce que j'étais tranquille en offrant
ma voix ou mon silence ou est-ce que
finalement j'ai mis plein de mots pour
masquer quelque chose de ma gêne
est-ce que j'ai pu vraiment accueillir
ce cadeau ouvrir mon cœur
parce que c'est pas rien ce qui vient de
se passer là
alors on va inverser les rôles les solos
vous avez une deuxième chance de le
faire et peut-être d'observer si quelque
chose a changé donc je vous invite
maintenant à faire la deuxième partie
allez-y
je t'offre quelque chose de moi
merci
merci de votre participation qu'est-ce
qu'il s'est passé pour vous
est-ce qu'il y a du rire qui masque un
peu quelque chose de peut-être pas
facile à l'intérieur
est-ce que mon cadeau offrir cette
vibration sonore ou silencieuse c'était
totalement détendu ou est-ce qu'il y
avait un peu de tension un peu de choses
inconfortables
est-ce que j'ai vraiment pu goûter ce
que l'autre me ferait
pour terminer vous allez pouvoir mettre
vos mains en prière devant votre
poitrine et puis vous inclinez face à
votre partenaire ou à vous-même pour le
faire un Namasté
Namasté qui signifie à la fois je te
remercie et je t'onore telle que tu es
et si vous le souhaitez si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez vous asseoir
alors de nos jours le Tantra ça se
pratique plutôt en groupe au cours de
stage ou d'atelier avec de l'expérience
ça peut aussi se pratiquer au quotidien
puisqu'il s'agit de mettre de la
conscience et de l'énergie sur ce qu'on
vit
si vous étiez une petite souris et puis
que vous ouvriez la porte où il y a des
gens qui sont en train de pratiquer du
Tantra qu'est-ce que vous verriez et
bien peut-être déjà en train de parler
ou des gens en train de danser des
personnes en train de se regarder ou en
train de se masser ou peut-être des gens
qui font monter leur énergie tellement
fort qu'on croirait presque qu'il y a de
la folie dans la pièce
plein d'autres choses encore
alors vous vous demandez peut-être ce
que ça apporte
je peux vous dire ce que moi ça
m'apporte
le Tantra ça m'apporte de la sécurité
interne j'ai appris à faire attention à
ma sécurité interne j'ai appris à
repérer mes limites et aller respecter
davantage parce que la première personne
qui ne respectait pas mes limites
c'était moi
le Tantra ça m'apporte aussi de la
libération et de la liberté on dit que
c'est un chemin de déconditionnement
au cours de ma vie j'ai reçu plein
d'injonctions vous savez les petits
messages souvent non verbaux du style on
ne demande pas ça ne se fait pas
d'exprimer son désir vous la sexualité
c'est dangereux ma fille
débrouille-toi les autres ne sont pas là
pour t'aider
mais le temps très m'aide à repérer tous
ces messages qui œuvrent en souterrain
dans ma vie mais de façon puissante et
quand je les repères et bien là j'ai le
choix j'ai le choix de voir ce que dans
tout ça je veux garder et ce dont je ne
veux plus
et moi quand j'ai le choix librement de
faire ce que je veux dans ma vie je vais
plutôt vers les choses qui me font
plaisir donc il y a beaucoup plus de
plaisir dans ma vie
il y a plus de détente aussi d'une part
parce que on cherche toujours la détente
dans les pratiques mais il y a aussi
cette question du nom jugement alors le
non jugement c'est pas une histoire de
positivisme c'est pas qu'il faut bannir
les émotions dites négatives comme la
colère non on accueille tout ce qui
vient mais juste on l'observe on ne le
classe pas
alors le non jugement j'en avais
beaucoup entendu parler dans différentes
situations mais ça restait des mots un
peu creux pour moi avec le Tantra je
l'ai expérimenté et c'est comme si ça
s'était intégré dans mon corps
alors je ne suis pas encore Bouddha et
j'ai encore des jugements à l'intérieur
de moi mais j'en ai moins
et quand je me juge moins moi-même ça
fait de la détente ça fait comme une
ouverture de mon corps
ça fait aussi une ouverture de mon cœur
parce que je juge moins les autres et je
suis plus prête à les accueillir
donc mes relations sont plus fluides
plus tranquilles plus joyeuse plus
authentique aussi
j'ai 61 ans je suis enseignante de ton
train et même de voix est en train et
j'ai un rêve secret mon rêve c'est que
partout dans cette salle dans toutes les
rues de Lannion allez soyons fous dans
la France entière ou dans le monde
entier chacun et chacune puisse
plusieurs fois par jour s'autoriser à
faire
parce que faire du Tantra c'est mettre
de l'espace à l'intérieur de soi c'est
mettre de l'espace dans son corps c'est
mettre de l'espace dans son cœur c'est
mettre de l'espace dans sa vie et avec
cet espace là la joie peut venir
merci de votre écoute avant qu'on se
quitte il faut qu'on perce notre bulle
là est-ce que vous êtes prêts mettez vos
doigts comme ça on la perd tous ensemble
on a besoin de tous les doigts allez 1 2
Namasté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]